first we've got some new information
about the road map to easing
lockdown that the prime minister is
going to announce tomorrow downing
street has just revealed
that there is a criteria of four tests
that will determine
whether the government will decide to
move on to the next step
of easing we can show you those tests
now whether the government's vaccine
deployment program
continues to be rolled out successfully
is number one
it will also require evidence that
vaccines are effective in reducing
hospitalizations and deaths
among those who have been vaccinated it
will depend on infection rates not
risking a surge in hospitalizations that
will put
unsustainable pressure on the nhs and
finally that the assessment of risks is
not changed fundamentally
by new covid variants well sky sam
coates is still in downing street for us
sam it is very clear isn't it the prime
minister is being extremely cautious
that's right jonathan the speculation is
over we can now give you confirmed
details
of boris johnson's lockdown lifting plan
that we outlined
uh tomorrow to parliament now this plan
has four
stages as well and each of those stages
is about
five weeks apart and that gives the
government time to assess using the
criteria that you just
uh read out that there aren't any uh
problems the
the four stages begin on march the
eighth and at the end of those four
stages that should take us
uh to roughly the end of june and by
that stage the idea
is that pretty much everything in
britain or more specifically england
which is what
this plan uh pertains to should be
reopened it won't be
exactly as it was before coronavirus
there'll still be social distancing
there's uncertainty
around international travel but more or
less they want everything to be reopened
by
the end of june now here's some
specifics march the 8th
all schools in england reopen also
you will be able to meet one other
individual outside
for social reasons now at the moment you
can only do that for exercise
but for march the eighth you can do that
socially as well
then fast forward three weeks march the
29th is the next point at that point
quite a big
change one household will be allowed to
meet another
household outside anywhere in other
words
families will be able to meet each other
potentially
in private gardens also the rule of six
will kick in so it's not two households
then up to six
uh individuals and the ability to meet
in uh particularly in private gardens
mean westbrook quietly the return of
barbecues
for easter at this point as well march
29th you'll have tennis courts
basketball courts other outdoor sports
reopening
as well but know what that doesn't mean
over the easter school holidays which
begin on march the 29th you're not going
to be able to go away to self-catering
accommodation in england for instance or
you're not going to be able
uh to sit in pub gardens at that point
for that you're going to have to reach
wait for the next stage which is
roughly middle of the middle of april
now boris johnson will set all of this
out tomorrow
and then parliament and the country will
give its verdict